hi my name is Lucas a furry and I'm from
Porto Alegre Brazil I want to come here
to share my experiences that I've been
through leaving my home country and
coming to the United States to pursue
acting and I hope at the end of this
video that you grab all this information
that I'm giving you filter and use this
knowledge to your favor so the first
thing I want to share with you is that
there's a lot of opportunity here in Los
Angeles specifically but there's also a
lot of people trying to do the same
thing as yourself there's a lot of
people who think that you just come here
in the first year you're going to be in
a huge film and in reality that's that's
not what it's not what it happens you
should consider this as any other
business it's a marathon
rather a sprint I think you can use that
mat for oh yeah he he got his Oscar when
he was 27 but then when you researched
about it he is he joined the Union when
he was 16 so he's been working for 11
years in this industry and another thing
to really consider is budgeting if
you're coming from from Brazil for
example if you come from Brazil you
think about currency consider having a
car Los Angeles is a huge city and it's
very spread out consider how much money
you're going to spend on rent this is
not a cheap town to live in really
consider budgeting yourself this is a
business where actors need to have a
thick skin this is a business where you
get a lot of nose rather than yes as you
go submit yourself to thousands not I
don't know from that thousand the
project you submit you get a hundred
auditions from the one hundred Aleutians
you get two callbacks and from maybe one
of those you get the job so there's a
lot of nose for a yes you're too tall
you're too blonde you're too brunette
you're too fat you're too thin you
always you too something is just like
that was not for you the next one will
be so just put yourself there and just
continue this journey if you're starting
this career
what you really need to have is a
headshot and a resume and that's it a
photo of your face so casting directors
can see it's like oh I I like this
person this is what I want to see in my
project see his resume
oh okay he done he have done this this
and that I want to call him for an
audition and then there you have you you
have the opportunity of work I strongly
recommend to not focus on trying to find
an agent focus your self on having a
good body of work experience have a lot
of project if you've worked on so you
can have footage to build your demo reel
which is a video of projects that you've
worked compressed that into Clips the
the best part of those projects and
compress that into a very short video
that's a demo reel and also have clips
so if I have a project that I've done a
comedy grab a 10 to 15 second clip of
that if I have a really dramatic scene
that I loved it
grab the 15 to 20 second part of that
scene have clips of it so you can submit
yourself that's another thing I'm going
to talk about if you're new to this town
and you don't know anyone you have to
start submitting yourself and the good
news is that there's a lot of media
places that you can do that for example
la casting or actors access it's a web
page you put your headshot you put your
resume you put clips you put your demo
reel and there's a lot of casting
directors that submit their projects
over there and they're search for a
specific type and then you can self
submit yourself another thing I want to
talk about is extra work it's a great
way for inexperienced people to be on a
professional set and to learn build your
network get close to the director if
well depending on the size of the
project but maybe the director won't
even talk to you but build your network
because maybe you meet someone on a
project that you being an extra and that
person maybe he's doing your project two
months from now and it's gonna oh I
really like that person gonna call him
to see if he's interested in this
project and this is what will make you
pursue this career and go into that
direction wrapping it up tips that I
want to give you guys is don't give up
this is something
that there's a lot of bumps into it but
it's a beautiful journey if you love
doing this you will have strength to
pursue this and you will do it but also
really treat this as a business create
your own work put yourself there foams
nowadays have a great camera on it
create your own work and put it out
there maybe someone will watch it's like
well this so it's such a creative way of
doing this build your own work this is
all about the journey do whatever you
can to pursue this and you will succeed
I hope you guys enjoy and I hope to see
you in person soon